Це останні з гірників. Незабаром вони заступлять на свою зміну
Деякі працюють під землею вже десятиліттями
Приміром, Сіддік Еміноглу,
якого всі тут називають просто Зіґґі
Шахта Проспер-Ганіель
у німецькому містечку Ботроп
була потужним гірничопромисловим підприємством
У чотири зміни на глибині 1200 метрів
тут працювали гірники
і видобули тисячі тонн кам'яного вугілля
Сіддік Еміноглу добре пам'ятає, як він уперше спустився в шахту
Уперше, коли я спускався, я був ще стажером
Тоді гірники супроводжували учнів
Ми оглянули запасні виходи - про всяк випадок.
І все ж це було неймовірно
У шахті, де ще недавно видобували вугілля, тепер триває демонтаж
Усі машини, кабелі, арматуру
потрібно підняти нагору
Трохи сумно, тому що ми певною мірою
є свідками цілої епохи, що минає
Цієї роботи ніколи більше не буде
І це якось сумно, скажімо так
Роками ми видобували вугілля
І ось тепер, одразу, все закінчилося.
Все-таки це важко
Вагонетка за вагонеткою - все піднімають на поверхню
Більшість машин продадуть Туреччині або Китаю
Багатьом не подобається, що їхня техніка
розпродається конкурентам
які постачають до Німеччини дешевше вугілля
Якби ви зараз бачили,
що відбувається на дільниці демонтажу
Як швидко все відбувається
За один день розібрали стометрову протипожежну конструкцію
її залишилося лише підняти нагору
Все закінчується набагато швидше, ніж я думав,
і це сумно
Демонтаж шахти триватиме
до кінця наступного року
Потім шахту забетонують і наповнять водою
Для того, щоб ця вода не потрапила в питну воду
встановлять насоси, які мають працювати безперестанно
Ось так закінчується цІла епоха
Багато шахтарів хочуть зберегти
що-небудь на пам'ять
часто це шолом, іноді
коробка для нюхального тютюну
Без гірської промисловості Рурський регіон
ніколи б не став
найбільшою агломерацією в Німеччині
Шахти, коксові печі та сталеливарні заводи
наклали свій відбиток на формування регіону
А також трактири і поселення гірників поблизу шахт
Немає жодного міста, в якому б не було Гірничої або Шахтарської вулиці
Остання фотографія на пам'ять
Багато гірників навіть через десятиліття після виходу на пенсію
залишалися вірними своїм шахтам
і залишалися членами традиційних клубів шахтарів
Кілька тижнів тому населення офіційно попрощалося з гірничою справою
непростий момент для всіх
Так, звичайно, емоційно це для мене
дуже складна ситуація
Цього року в мене одразу три події
Я закриваю свою останню шахту, Німеччина припиняє видобуток кам'яного вугілля
і наприкінці року я йду на пенсію
Навряд чи можна пережити більше емоцій за короткий проміжок часу
Професія гірника завжди була небезпечною
У німецьких шахтах загинули тисячі працівників
Можливість покластися один на одного - це дуже важливо
Так виникла особлива культура стосунків
Ми сьогодні прощаємося
з чимось дуже для нас значущим
До Рурської області приїжджали звідусіль
Сім'я Сіддіка Еміноглу приїхала з Туреччини
Іноземні робітники були для гірничодобувної промисловості буденною справою
Походження не мало жодного значення
У шахті, під землею, всі чорні
Там немає національності чи віросповідання,
ти там просто шахтар
Усі чорні, різниці жодної
Разом вони співають пісню шахтаря, пісню друзів
У ці дні в Рурській області це головний музичний хіт
А справжнє прощання гірників із шахтою Проспер-Ганіель уже відбулося
воно було тільки для обраних.